Welcome to our Channel today we're
excited to explore one of the most
familiar yet surprisingly unique
agricultural products the onion how
exactly are these small bulbs
transformed into juice join us as we
step into the world of dedicated farmers
and modern processing plants to uncover
each fascinating step of this journey
onions are a globally popular crop with
leading producers including China India
and the United States every year these
countries Harvest and Export millions of
tons of onions with China at the
Forefront producing nearly 24 million
tons annually accounting for over 20% of
the world's total production India
follows closely with around 19 million
tons these countries play a crucial role
in supplying onions to Major markets
particularly in Asia Europe and the
Middle East the the Journey of an onion
begins in the fields where it is
cultivated and cared for through an
agricultural process tailored to its
specific growth needs onions thrive in
well- drained nutrient-rich soil
requiring plenty of sunlight and
moderate water to develop vigorously in
modern agriculture
Farmers have embraced the use of
automated onion planting machines to sew
seeds efficiently significantly reducing
the amount of manual labor required and
enhancing overall productivity these
State of-the-art machines are designed
to place seeds or small onion sets into
the soil with remarkable Precision
ensuring they are positioned at the
optimal depth and space at consistent
distant intervals guarantees that each
onion plant has adequate Room to Grow
minimizing the risk of overcrowding and
promoting healthier more uniform crop
development throughout months of careful
tending onions grow strong beneath the
ground with roots reaching deep for
nutrients while green stems rise above
to support this growth automated
irrigation systems provide the exact
amount of water needed keeping the soil
consistently moist without over
saturation during this time farmers use
a combination of organic and traditional
pest control methods to keep the onion
plants healthy and thriving after
approximately 3 to 4 months from
Planting onions is ready for Harvest
choosing the right timing is crucial as
harvesting too early will yield immature
onions lacking flavor while a delayed
Harvest may lead to spoilage typically
when the green onion tops begin to fall
over onto the ground it's a clear sign
that the onions are ready to be
harvesting onions with Machinery marks a
remarkable advancement in agriculture
saving significant time and
labor modern harvesting machines are
designed to lift onions with Precision
gently removing them from the ground
without causing damage the machines then
clean off excess soil and neatly arrange
the onions for Easy Transport this
automated process is not only
accelerates the Harvest but also ensures
that onions are collected clean and
intact ready for further processing and
storage after being high harvested the
onions are transported to processing
facilities where the transformation into
onion juice Begins the first step is
cleaning where the onions are placed on
a conveyor belt and thoroughly washed
Under Pressure nozzles and soaking tanks
to remove any dirt or remaining
impurities once cleaned the onions are
prepared for the juicing process these
preparation steps not only ensure
hygiene but also optimize extraction
preserving the natural flavor and
nutritional nutrition of the onions in
the final product after completing the
cleaning process the onions are
transferred to Industrial juicing
machines here the fresh onions are
crushed and pressed to extract pure
juice this pressing process must ensure
that the juice is efficiently filtered
retaining all the natural nutrients from
the onions to improve the texture and
smoothness consistency of the juice
workers may add a small amount of
natural powder such as rice or corn
flour this powder not only enhances the
mouth feel but also helps keep the
product stable preventing separation
during
storage additionally a small amount of
sugar syrup may be added to create
create a harmonious color making the
juice look more appealing while still
still preserving its inherent
nutritional values after juicing the
juice is heated to sterilize it
eliminating any harmful bacteria while
maintaining the nutritional value and
distinctive flavor of the onions
following the processing the juice is
transferred to an automatic bottling
system ensuring that each bottle is is
consistent and safe the juice bottles
are sealed and labeled with Complete
product information complying with
strict International standards in
preparation for export to various
markets
worldwide onion juice is not only a
nutrient-rich beverage but also offers
numerous health benefits it can contain
natural
anti-inflammatory and antibacterial
compounds that help support the body in
boosting the immune system and fighting
infections Additionally the components
and onion juice Aid digestion improve
blood circulation and enhance
cardiovascular health making it a
favorite Choice among health conscious
individuals around the world did you
know onions aren't just tasty but also
packed with nutrients that your body
loves a medium onion has only 44
calories but it's loaded with vitamins
and fiber it's especially high in
vitamin C which keeps your immune system
strong helps your body repair itself and
even absorbs iron better onions are full
of B vitamins like B6 and folate which
help your body stay energized and your
nerves work properly isn't isn't that
incredible for such a simple vegetable
let's talk about your heart for a second
onions are a Powerhouse for heart health
they're loaded with antioxidants and
compounds that fight inflammation lower
cholesterol and reduce
triglyceride that means they can help
protect you from heart disease and
here's the best part onions are packed
with cortine a super strong
anti-inflammatory
compound studies even show that onion
extracts can help lower high blood
pressure isn't it wild how something as
humble as an onion can do so much for
your heart onions aren't just healthy
they're super easy to include in your
meals you can eat them raw for a nice
crunch in your salads or guacamole or
cook them up for a sweet caramelized
flavor in your favorite dishes
they're not just making your food taste
better they're also giving your body
antioxidants fiber and so many vitamins
plus they're versatile enough to go in
almost anything you cook seriously next
time you're in the kitchen grab an onion
it's an easy way to stay healthy and
that wraps up today's video through this
presentation we've clearly seen the care
and effort that farmers and processing
facilities invest to bring us high
quality products that are not only
delicious but also beneficial for our
health if you enjoyed this video please
remember to like And subscribe to our
channel so you won't miss any exciting
content in the future and share your
thoughts in the comment section below
thank you and we look forward to seeing
you in our next videos Welcome to our
Channel
[Music]
a